[Music]
it was meant to hit face first into a
pillar but as I flew in I ended up going
my head first I'm on the mat going oh
let me see if I can still move my toe
when we rehearsed that one I had a
helmet on and I swung down I could hear
like rubbing on my head I think ah yeah
we should probably pull that safety line
up a little tighter
so then I tap Tyler to hit the brakes
and I'm looking going it's too late this
car is about to smash Sam in the legs I
was like holy cow like I had this moment
of like oh
what's up everybody we're back with
another episode of stuntman react and
we're here with an extra special fancy
guest Daniel Stevens Daniel's done a lot
of work what's some of this work that
you've done tell us a little bit about
yourself uh I mean I've been very lucky
I haven't started doing stunts in
Australia then moved over here La in
2006 being a tall white guy I've tended
to double a lot of superheroes yeah I've
doubled Wolverine on four films Iron Man
Thor Star-Lord Green Lantern don't
mention that one uh Winter Soldier uh
yeah that's probably about it that's
about it I tend to do a lot of fight
stuff and riding wires and yeah
generally getting beaten up for actors
oh great we're a bunch of Great Clips to
look at oh yeah and geez here too all
right guys yeah another superhero right
here yeah I got I got one under my belt
he's very accomplished as well but this
show is not about this is about Dale
Stevens this is not about me at all oh
dear yeah
all right well let's just jump into some
of the stuff that you've done guys
whatever this is Take It Outside
so is you huh that's me oh you can see
my backpack in that shot
yeah pretty hard yeah just the amount of
rehearsals we did my neck by even before
we shot this my neck was trash I could
no longer hold my head up is he wired up
to you or is he just hugging you and
hoping for the best that was actually
several pieces we run at each other the
first stunt where we run together and
I'm on a traveling rig and he's on a
traveling rig so he can do the gallop
and then I'm running basically into a
dead man but this time I'm actually
running into a ratchet so it's paying
out slack and as soon as we hit the guy
on the button hits it and Sam has to
grab me and then we get ratcheted
together so that's the first stunt and
then the second stunt was camera outside
the Breakaway doors are you landing on
any sort of pad or is that right into
the ground there was pads underneath and
then that rubber box stuff was put
across the top of it so it's a little
bit softer and then Sam ended up
trashing his hand because he had his
hand underneath me so I landed all my
weight on his hand get up got up in his
hands bleeding you know it's crazy like
you talk about this really intense setup
for like the tackle and all that kind of
stuff but what I see in the edit is just
like two quick insert shots yeah because
I mean as they like to do they want to
cut into the active's face so they're
cutting out of the tackle and they've
got to shut a few literally just
reacting and that's the beat just to tie
the actor into it pretty choppy that
edit at least they show the smack into
the ground through the door yeah exactly
that's true I'm not going to say this is
the greatest superhero
but for me it was some of the biggest
stunts I've done it was definitely the
most action I've done in a film and this
job was actually the first job I ever
met and worked with Sam Hargrave which
led to a long career of working together
there's lots of moments in this film
when we're working on it with Sam
Hargrove and I are starting and they're
doing a three two one count and we're
basically standing there hugging each
other yeah waiting for a stunt to happen
through the doors or there's another
tackle through a window like here we are
hugging again waiting for them stay
action all right
well there we go yeah that tackle
through the window is a good one wow so
that was three separate stunts all cut
together the first one is a tackle
through a practical window well a
breakaway window which is still real
glass but they use special effects
poppers to shatter the glass that
actually put a net outside the window
and then land in the net the Nets made
of row exactly that doesn't feel good
they put a top in the neck so so that
the glass wouldn't cut the net but then
we basically laying in a burrito full of
glass and get covered with glass shards
luckily Sam Hargrave he's on his back
he's got a big coat on him but I had a
tank top but my shoulders are all cut up
he had glass all down the back of his
neck and then we have to slowly crawl
out of this thing so that wasn't fun so
then the next take is from the outside
of the window we basically do a ratchet
so there's another one Sam and I are
hugging each other we're in for the
countdown three two one get ratcheted
out the window and do a big pendulum
swing and no impact so that was actually
pretty fun ride and then they're looking
at the glass because there's four panes
of glass we went through the bottom two
they're meant to pop all four panes of
glass but the top two break so then we
had to come back and do the same stunt
again the next day and then they popped
all four Windows which you see from this
angle they popped all four but then the
outside they didn't use that shot
interesting they used the first shot
where the glass didn't even break and
then the third shot is US looking
straight down and just getting on a
descender drop straight down on onto the
concrete which was padded concrete
Tiffany aches that persists from the
ears of stunt work uh my back's not good
yeah I had two herniated discs one of
them actually was in free guy
where I was flying flat and it was meant
to hit face first into a pillar and then
spin off it and there's a dead man right
on my back which is meant as soon as I
get there's what's going to spin me back
because I flew in I ended up going my
head first and then just scorpioned my
back so bad bent backwards and I heard a
crack in my neck and my lower back I'm
on the mat going oh let me see if I can
still move my toes I'm like yeah I think
I can but that was not good funny thing
was it cuts from my practical hit then
into another visual effects stunt to the
ground so it could have been all visual
effect but other than that I mean it's
not injury wise have been pretty
fortunate got 15 stitches above my eye
on that first Wolverine and that's
really the only time I've been to
hospital from set dude playtime's over
catch me I don't know
this one was practical stunt on a wire
basically get thrown and slide across
the concrete the first take of that one
I'd actually landed with my arm up and I
felt my shoulder again I was like oh
yeah that's not good so then the second
take I touch my shoulder under like yep
that hurts just as much
oh man eventually we got the shots
that's good yeah what was the surface
for that one because there's no Road
Rash there was padding so about an inch
of foam but then a slighty born
plywood kind of stuff so it's still hard
but then they put this like shuffleboard
wax on the surface which is super
slippery so you're still landing on a
hard surface but it's got a bit of
cushion for the impact and actually in
that shot I was wearing an elbow pad and
just had a flesh colored sleeve on it
and then oh that's nice yeah and that's
where VFX can be your friend definitely
these days can you wear pads more
frequently and have VFX paint them out
or is it still kind of like a hey your
character's in a muscle shirt good luck
you can definitely and well not just
wearing pads but padding your set and
the floor you can paint that stuff out a
lot easier
he basically just picked me up and
tackled me to the ground we had padding
on the ground so it wasn't too bad the
stunt coordinator Chris O'Hara goes just
get more height in this last one and he
just took me straight up and straight
down and landed his 315 pounds of his
shoulder straight into my chest oh my
God I thought I broke on my wrist it was
a hard impact oh my God
and I think in the end they still use
the flat I take anyway
come on
there's a close-up of the hands
squeezing Ryan's chest and then he's
grabbing Aaron's wrists so in that shot
that's actually my hand on the right
side and Ryan's hand on the left side
and Aaron's just squeezing a dummy yeah
wow yeah hey you guys want to keep up
with us see what's going on with Daniel
Stevens and other great stunt performers
click that subscribe button
[Music]
this is uh Tony Scott right Tony Scott's
last film this job was really fun
basically just doing practical stunts
real stuff real trains I mean there were
some visual effects there's a shot where
I fall between the train carriages there
was a line basically to stop me from
going down here right yeah so they've
got to paint out stuff like that but it
was still practical fall between train
cars at 40 miles an hour
yeah there we go that's you on a moving
train doing that that's all practical 40
miles an hour wow just trustful
basically when we rehearsed that one I
had a helmet on and I swung down and my
helmet was on the tracks I could hear
like rubbing on my head I'm like ah yeah
we should probably pull that safety line
up a little tighter and then the
craziest part of that was just breathing
in all this like uh what was it like
sawdust it was potato flakes and puffed
wheat because they needed something
biodegradable right because they're just
dumping tons of it out into the
countryside in Ohio they just had these
mortars firing this crap in my face and
it was so hard to breathe every breath
would be sucking that stuff in I'd try
and cough and get fresh air in and every
breath was sucking more in that was
worse than the hanging between the train
cars because wow at that stage I'm just
trying not to suffocate yeah yeah you
see the close-up shots
it's crazy apparently afterwards they're
just all this deer coming out of the
forest oh bad living on this stuff yeah
so then I swing down on purpose but yeah
the first take I was not needed a chance
to change your pants off to that one the
first take we're doing 40 miles an hour
and the stunt coordinator is like you
got to be aware of that wind shear as
you jump off and I'm thinking it's not
it can't be that bad right because I'm
already going 40. so it's not like the
wind's going to change when I jump but
as soon as I jump that pulled me about
maybe two feet to the right and I'm
jumping to grab two handrails and I
jumped out and completely missed that
left one and just grabbed both hands on
that right hand round so tight and I
swung down my feet clipped the [ __ ] like
the boulders at the bottom hit that uh
Swan and pulled myself up so tight like
hanging on death grip onto the handrail
like the holy cow that's scared the crap
out of me and then Tony Scott came up
afterwards he's like did you mean to
fall down like that and I was like no
not really and it goes can you do it
again I was like
yeah I can do that
now that I know it's coming I can
actually do it on purpose but yeah the
first one scared the crap out of me
after a while I started getting a little
cocky with them at my feet come down and
hit hard and then I had to remind myself
we're actually doing 40 miles an hour
right so it's not it's not smooth
concrete either so you hit that gravel
and it gets a bit of a whip action
what exactly was your position for this
film this film directed by Sam Hargrave
who I first worked with on X-Men Origins
Wolverine lots of hugs 15 years later
now he's a director yeah and he has me
stunt coordinate his first film see what
happens when you hug somebody yeah
Sam knew exactly what he wanted and we
needed the camera in a lot of risky
spots Sam was actually operating camera
strapped to the front of a Polaris ATV
flying through traffic I'm sitting in
the back seat of the Polaris the head
rigger is hanging out of the side and
then a stunt guy Tyler Whitey is driving
the Polaris so he's chasing that car and
then at the right moment I have to tap
him on the shoulder so he gets on the
brakes and then the camera is basically
over the foot of the card or reverse 180
and each time the car is a bit far away
so then I'm just waiting a little longer
I'm like I'm going to get it even closer
which was if that was a camera guy I
would never take that risk but because
he's my friend I could break his legs
so then I tapped Tyler to hit the brakes
and I'm looking going it's too late this
car is about to smash Sam in the legs I
was like holy cow and he just got over
the hood and it was so good but I was
like I had this moment of like oh I've
just ruined the film normally the hugs
will see this yeah so Ash Aquila our
head rigger he disconnect Sam right as
we hit the brakes and then he jumps off
and then Sam jumps the camera through
the window and the window frame there is
the Stitch
it's really cool I love that stuff
Hemsworth actually showed up for this
job three days before we started
shooting and we went straight into this
sequence
he's a legit kickboxer he's martial art
stuff's really good that fall across
through the awning there is that a real
guy taking that hit all the way down to
the concrete or what do you think that
was I think that's a dummy it was a
dummy a lot of people don't realize it
but yeah it was a dummy and the falling
through the top is what helps hide it as
well and it's helped because he's meant
to be dead when he goes over so he
should be a limp body there's another
dummy in the movie somewhere else maybe
your followers in the comments can see
see if they can say where it is it's not
in the water but it's in another scene
in the movie there it's a dummy that
gets wrecked
okay
that's Randy he's a massive star in
India I mean to us he was just the cool
dude came in rehearsed doing all this
stuff getting gritty learning all the
fights so Dan Carter is doubling ran
deep and then Bobby Hampton doubling
Hemsworth they go off and Dan Carter
landed with his foot underneath him and
he broke his foot watch his foot yeah
see his foot's underneath and completely
twist his ankle backwards and then he
still gets up and does two more takes
after that hell yeah Dan Carter tough as
hell yeah so his foot is broken now take
three and Sam's like ah we need to go
again and so I go to Dan I'm like this
is where it's up to the stunt guy like I
have to trust his judgment like I'm like
can you do it again I'm not he's like
yeah I can do it again just give me a
minute he's like I sing it he didn't
know his foot was broken he knew he'd
hurt his foot but it still hurt so he
straps it up we give him a 10-15 minutes
take fire goes off
still doesn't Stitch to the shot before
and by now his foot is throbbing and
it's so much harder for him to push off
over this Edge and he doesn't get as
much push off and he came up short and
this is the shot that made the film and
he actually gets knocked out out cold in
this take so you watch him hear the back
of his head Clips the edge of the truck
instead of heading onto the top I mean
everything's padded that's all pads in
the back and the edge of the truck has
two inches of foam on it but it's so
much Whiplash on his neck that he's out
cold he has a broken foot down and the
shot actually he's kind of cool like
originally he was dropping out further
and clipping the edge of the awning but
this one it looks like he's trying to
grab the gun as he's going it was
actually a really cool shot that one won
a World stun award for him hardest hit
the more I talk to you guys the more
it's like the point is to make it look
like you wreck yourself for a shot to be
able to get back up right and do it
again and yeah come back the next day
and do it again it's a job you're not
trying to just do a daredevil thing
where you put it all on the line for
that one day and then you're done you
need to be able to go to work the next
day and the next day and the next day so
it's all about reducing the risks and
making it safe as possible and nowadays
visual effects helps a ton special
effects helps a ton so you can hide pads
you can hide wires and make things safer
there's a lot more paperwork if you do
get injured on set but nobody wants to
fill up people yeah exactly but I mean
it still happens you still get injured
but it's not the goal and it's not go
out of your way to wreck yourself to the
point where you cannot work again okay
so you guys saw a piece of extraction we
saw one dummy according to Daniel
Stevens though there's two more dummy
scenes in that film I want you guys to
put in the comments exactly where those
dummy scenes are yo gee that gives me an
even better idea not just dummy scenes
in that film I want you to tell us about
your favorite dummy scenes of any film
and you can't see that dummy from
Kingsman we've already seen it we've
seen that yet yeah
everything you told us about was awesome
learning about the long take extraction
all the ratchets and wire poles that
you've done even going back like looking
at the original Wolverine and like
seeing how hard some of those hits were
how much whiplashes
all these shots like I've never I've
never paid attention to how much
Whiplash happens in all these shots I
think I've I think I saw like three
different people get like five
concussions over the course of the past
hour here yeah right if people want to
follow your your exploits if they want
to like see the work that you do is
there a place where they could follow
you yeah most of my stuff's on Instagram
Daniel Stevens one number one I'm on
Tick Tock as well I think it's Daniel
Stevens stunts I really appreciate you
joining us and like telling us some of
your stories and sharing some things
happening it's my pleasure anytime well
thank you so much for watching everybody
go give Daniel a shout and tell him that
he does some awesome work and thank him
for being on the show with us yeah I
mean you definitely can't come back yeah
cool yeah
there's a lot of movies on your IMDb
list that like would be worth talking
about yeah sure anytime I may not I'll
be here see you next time see you next
time peace there is a team behind the
performer that's performing The Stunt
gag the riggers and the riggers have a
dance that they play with the performer
which is working on the count doing the
pull three two one
Paul of course will either lift or yank
or cause a fly of some sort of motion